[Musique]
le beau temps est de retour sur nous les
sur le bâtiment de l'office de l'eau
créé en 2003 par le département et
l'association observatoire réunionnais
de l'eau l'office de loi pour objectif
de veiller au bon état des masses d'eau
continental et côtières durant la saison
des pluies l'ensemble de la ressource en
eau doit se recharger depuis quatre ans
les précipitations sont insuffisantes
jusqu'au mois de janvier dont on a une
situation déficitaire que ce soit dans
les cours d'eau et dans les nappes
c'est à dire une situation était
inférieur à la normale les
précipitations de carlos au mois de
février et les pluies qui ont suivi
également au mois de février ont permis
de remonter un peu les niveaux le niveau
dans les rivières et les nappes
cependant on n'est pas encore revenu à
une situation normale l'autre rôle de
l'office de l'eau et d'accompagner les
établissements d'intérêt public tels que
les fermiers qui potabilisée ou
assainissent la ressource en eau des
subventions à l'équipement afin de
limiter l'impact écologique de l'homme
dans le cycle de l'eau le relevé par
moyens importants en ce sens que pour
des besoins premiers d'irrigation
agricole
on va y apprendre de l'eau du sucre en
deux parties
rivière et sur quelques points dans la
nappe pompage et ses preuves mais qui en
prend l'étape de traitement qui est de
la responsabilité de la collectivité
commune ou un peu comme les
précipitations annuelles sont de 7,6
milliards de mètres cubes par an 220
millions de mètres cubes sont prélevés
chaque année pour l'eau potable
l'irrigation et l'industrie 800 millions
de mètres cubes sont prélevés pour
l'hydroélectricité soit 1,02 milliard de
mètres cubes d'eau pour tous les usages
[Musique]